COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some thankful
developers come to terms
with resident instances.
Is their performance cup
half full or half empty?
Stay tuned to find out.
I was attending a
meetup last week
where I was approached
by some developers
at a company called
Think Thanks,
a nonprofit whose goal
is to improve the quality
and frequency of thanks given
to people and organizations.
They were a great
group of folks who
built their service
on App Engine
and had already done all of
the cold-boot optimization
that we could
possibly talk about.
Still, they were seeing issues
when sudden traffic came in.
Their problem was that the app
traffic was extremely bursty.
They would go from
zero users for hours
to suddenly thousands.
And in those
situations, instances
were legitimately
being cold booted,
causing a delay in
overall performance
while that instance
was being created.
The latency of Think Thanks
was taking considerable hit
any time a new instance
was being booted up.
So besides just
adjusting the scheduler
to boot up less
instances, it looks
like they needed something
stronger to handle
sudden spikes in traffic.
There was really only one
thing left to suggest to them--
resident instances.
As I talked about before, the
App Engine serving algorithms
are constantly deciding
on whether it's better
to queue a request or
spin up a new instance.
This takes into account
a significant number
of factors to decide
when this should happen.
If your cold boot time
is significant, then
during extreme
spikes in traffic,
request latency will
suffer as those requests
sit longer in the work
queue before being serviced.
This could flood
your application
with a huge amount
of startup costs
and delay the entire
system significantly.
This is where resident
instances come in.
A resident instance is
one that stays alive 24/7
and only receives traffic
under a very specific situation
while a new instance
is booting up.
Basically, resident instances
are spare instances.
While a new instance
is booting up,
they handle the excess
load that the new instance
would be handling.
Once it's up and
running, the traffic
is sent to the new instance
and the resident one
can go back to waiting around.
Which is really
important because it
means that user
requests won't be
subject to sudden
spikes in latency that
come from cold-boot performance,
which is exactly what I saw
when we changed the main idle
instances flag of Think Thanks
to one.
Once the new request
load came in,
it was handled by
the existing instance
so that latency didn't
shoot through the roof
while the new one
was booting up.
The takeaway?
Resident instances are
the key to rapid scale
and not having your user
perception of latency
be impacted.
But after playing around with
resident instances a bit,
Think Thanks noticed
that there seemed
to be a plus-one tax involved
in situations where traffic
was lower than normal.
Basically, if no one had
been using their application
for a while, a
sudden burst would
cost two instances,
the idle instance
as well as the new
instance being spun up.
But for infrequent traffic, that
really wasn't what they needed.
Think Thanks was
wasting an instance.
An alternative solution
came from a Google post
where a community member
described a similar problem.
His startup process might
take multiple seconds
in order to fill a database.
But rather than using
resident instances,
he created and used a cron
job to ping the instance
and keep it alive indefinitely.
When we tried this
on Think Thanks,
we saw pretty much
what we expected.
In the lowest volume
setting, this setup
allowed their back end to keep
from spawning a new instance
when it didn't need to.
Happy with their latency
improvement, the Think Thanks
folks finished their
meetup-provided pizza
and then went happily
along their way.
Afterwards, I talked to
a few App Engine experts
who wanted to make it very clear
that there's two very distinct
and separate use cases here.
If you have a high
frequency, lots of instance
churn scenario and a
slow cold boot time,
then resident instances
are your best bet.
However, if you have a
low frequency traffic
with occasional bursts
in a slow cold boot time,
then keeping an
always-cron instance around
is ideal since you can
handle the initial traffic
load gracefully with a lower
number of total instances.
The downside to both
of these situations
is that these persistent
instances come at a cost.
You're basically
paying for an instance
to be alive 24/7, which
could add significant costs
to your operating budget.
Which is why I like to say that
you should always carefully
balance your tradeoffs
before making decisions
to go forward with any
performance improvements.
And to understand what
types of trade there are,
make sure to check out the
rest of the Google Cloud Atlas
videos.
Because when it
comes to your users,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]